the Joe Rogan experience yeah are you um
like do you think the rules are okay no
what would you change
I uh I would definitely change the
twelve to six elbow
that's one yeah I um you know what that
one's illegal right yeah yeah so stupid
I used to watch those those he's come on
late at night on ESPN I used to watch
those things all the time I still love
him to even what even when I was
fighting I was still watching those
things because it was at a Damon those
they they get they get so intense to you
know the athletic commissions really
thought that you couldn't do that to a
person because you'd kill them so they
made that technique illegal at all the
[ __ ] like we have that power cube thing
in the back we're gonna register that
power punch if you go out there at elbow
that thing you'd be shocked at how we
cast your elbow yes especially a
drop-down elbow like it's just not that
much power it's it's just I mean when
they're breaking those boys yeah they're
using that that joint as a letter post
as a letter exactly and they're just
putting their body weight behind it yeah
that's all it is you can't necessarily
do that when you're inside someone's
guard right you don't want Jon Jones
elbowing you in the face period exactly
but there's no difference if John's
hitting you with a downward elbow like
he got disqualified for when he fought
Matt Hamill or if he's hitting you at a
sideways elbow he's in smashing you you
know what that downwards elbow is gonna
cut a lot less unless it's the point on
the top of the head that's true that's
that's that's that's a very important
point like that was always the the
argument against no gloves was that
you'd cut you cut people want yeah I I
agree with that I mean that that skin
getting pinched between bone and that
speed you know just get torn yeah really
cut but do you think that having wrapped
up hands and having padded gloves like
is that an unrealistic sort of thing
because like if you're if you're
striking sit like if you Anna dude we're
just fighting right you're just fighting
like there's no like hey this is a play
fight or we're gonna have rules
this is just a fight you and a guy are
fighting you can't just hit them with
bare hands the way you can hit them with
gloves on with your wrists taped up you
know you got to be very wary about
punching them full blast in the forehead
you might shatter your hand there's a
lot of things you have to think about
yeah but I guess as as if someone has
done it and trained to to try to knock
someone out but you're not thinking
about you know we're never throwing
punches at your skull right you know
we're aiming for these targets that are
soft for sure so like when you're in a
street fight like those things don't
turn off right so so as a fighter I know
I'm that's not a concern to me in a
street fight situation when you bring
that up but I know it can happen I mean
it happened in some of the early ufc's
guys guys break their hands on skulls
that's what I'm saying is it unrealistic
to put gloves on someone and tape their
wrist up when they don't give them any
other advantage for striking any other
way you don't let them cast up your
ankles or do something where you you
know you protect your shins and make it
easier for you to kick hard because if
you had like some sort of spandex thing
with a like a shin pad like like the
same sort of thickness of shin pad as
you have on the knuckles you would just
be slamming into everything yeah elbows
arms who gives a [ __ ] you wouldn't worry
about it just slam it in there boom it
would change the game hey whatever it
would completely change the game but it
would slow it down a lot more I mean in
MMA fights now you look at a punch out
for him a fight versus a boxing match
yeah of course they can only punch so so
the punch counts higher but your hands
are getting hurt you know guys guys will
lose fights simply because they can't
continue going into the second round
sometimes will that be the case or will
it change their style it will definitely
change the style but without having the
gloves and hand wraps and and that stuff
there there is going to be those times
when it's still gonna be it's just gonna
minimum not minimize but bring the
number down you know it's not gonna stop
it though I agree I mean I think if I
wanted to look at it in terms of just
pure entertainment value I'd say leave
it the way it is yeah absolutely changed
downward elbows changed a couple other
things yes and some things like I like
yeah rules including with the judging
with the pride was judging fight judge
the whole fight I agree with that I like
that I agree with that and I think more
judges you know but I think that's a big
one I was talking about with that with
Pat Miletich the other day we're saying
like five judges or more you know yeah
yeah three yeah I agree I agree with
more judges you'll get a little more
diversity also though I think you got a
change change the the scoring criteria I
mean we are using a boxing criteria but
like like when you talk about wrestling
and when I see guys go oh he's going to
take down when a guy goes down he pops
right back up I'm like it's not a
takedown it's not - right you know so so
like why can't we implement some of the
things because we're taking aspects of
all these different styles of fighting
mm-hmm like the route the scoring system
and the values for things should should
come from that to some degree yeah I
would take down with the immediate
stand-up like if someone takes you down
you're right back up that is not a whole
lot different than you blocking a kick
yeah you know just blocking a kick count
if you get your knee up and your elbow
you catch one right here are you
counting as something that guys yeah
right no no not so you know who does
Greg Jackson he's a great coach you have
he so he I think he does his
psychological thing I'm letting the cat
out of the bag with this one because I'm
in the cage was with Isaac Valley flag
and Isaac throws a kick and I block it
ain't Gregg's like it's a great kick
guys a great kick Ike that landed me you
know and I'm like I mean he does
something else and it doesn't affect me
but he's cheering him more like it does
and I'm like is he doing that for the
rat for the judges I'm like and I went
back to the corner I told Mike as like
Mike he's cheering him on getting kind
of getting the judges on his side Mike's
like don't worry about that this is what
you need to do yeah you got to get that
[ __ ] out of your head yeah for sure for
sure but if he's right there look if you
see where one corner is and then the
other corner is when the fight is not
going on there over there by the stairs
the judge is right there yep the judge
is just a few feet over and if they're
like enthusiastic yes you got it you
gotta get those judges a certain percent
let's say thirty
don't know what the [ __ ] they're
watching and so they're very say named
number no let's not say
because I know what we'd say we'd all
say the same name unfortunately nice
lady
anyway this this [ __ ] situation it's
there should be way better judges for
sure yeah I think guys were former
fighters guys here martial arts experts
guys who like really care about the
sport you have no shortage of them you
can go to any MMA school any jujitsu
school any kickboxing school any website
any website all across the country and
you will find hundreds and hundreds of
qualified candidates people that will
tell you why that's a bad decision
people that'll tell you why that doesn't
work people who tell you why this
shouldn't mean anything and we don't
have that right now for no reason
there's like zero reason it doesn't make
any sense it's not like well man there's
not enough money like what is this no
there's enough money for it this is just
crazy this is no reason it's not like
well you know water is wet and that's
just how it goes
no I would think would be a good thing
also now that like the second generation
I I have like in my head I have this
three generations of MA and that's where
we are now in the third starting to move
into the fourth and I feel like with the
first two generations being done pretty
much yeah like there's a lot of guys
that are highly qualified to - yeah way
more
[Applause]